do you guys believe in child support
like well I don't I don't ask for child
support oh okay cool I feel
um I feel that it should happen but like
I said I'm realistic if
my child is not
an item that needs to be managed my
child so I'll look after you I'll do
what I need to if you can't think of
doing the same as a father then that's
on you
if that if the father pays like child
support does do you think he should get
50 50 custody with the chart with the
child if you want to you no oh no why
not because some fathers choose to pay
child support because they don't want to
be in the child's life
so if I'm talking about the ones that do
the ones that do yeah we were talking
about the the fathers that do want to be
in their child's life um do I believe in
child support in that instance
um depending on how the situation played
out I think that one is circumstantial
you see when it comes to 50 50 I think
no offense it's all about how your
parenting skills for me if your
parenting skills don't align
then all your parenting skills are not a
positive impact on the child then I
don't think you should have 50 50
because it confuses the child if we
can't sit there makes that decision we
can sit down together and say okay this
is what I think like for instance don't
let the kids watch certain things don't
let kids eat drink certain things so you
know they must read they must do that
and if I see that we've we've
established that that's what should
happen and that's not being done then
you can't have 50 because the things
that we're asking for that I'm asking
for is something to benefit the child
it's not got anything personal to do
with me or to do with anything that I
think I think definitely how do you say
you're right though yeah no I'm saying
like like because I I like I come from a
family of 10 and they were very loose
like we could pretty much do whatever we
wanted from from like yeah no like
really a lot of freedom and everyone
turned out good they're functioning
membership Society sorry two-parent home
yes yes but and so they both agree right
but what I'm saying is that you how do
you know you're correct like maybe
that's his parenting style would have
been better
I think it depends on actually having a
conversation yeah
yeah like she said because I feel like
me personally if for example you don't
want your kids to watch TV at three
doesn't necessarily mean I'm a bad
parent before yeah 100 because I my
child watches TV whatever she wants yeah
but that doesn't necessarily mean I'm
raising her the wrong way if I'm seeing
impacts of their behavior changing at
school and it's being raised to my it's
been brought to my attention and stuff
like that then we need to discuss like
whether we're not together that's so
different from these kids so we need I
believe when you choose to be a single
parent you have to realize that it's
probably harder than being in together
being together is a lot easier than
being a single parent so you now have to
learn how to have people skills
management skills all of that because
there's going to be some sort of
resentment until you've healed right so
I feel like you have to be able to sit
down and talk together and say okay this
is what I want what do you want or this
is what I want okay let's meet halfway
and if you can't have those kind of
conversations together then it's just
going to be difficult well no I agree
it'll be difficult I just don't like
like to me that's not enough to ask for
not splitting custody my children for me
my children's upbringing is enough for
me to well I'm saying like I don't think
legally that's fair it may not be fair
legally but so many things are not fair
legally so well I know they benefit the
women typically but I've said that yeah
yeah I've said that but um there's some
men as well they're not happy with the
way women bring
women as well not all women raise
children well so it's not I don't even
think it should be a based on
who's a better parent and it's hard you
know what some people won't accept it
but some men are better parents than
women as well but no I I agree but I'm
saying I'm saying like off the bat I
think it should be 50 50. and if there's
no abuse it should stay 50. I agree and
I don't think anyone's entitled to child
support I don't understand like why you
get a reward I think child's putting up
a home child support should be offered
to you if you are financially not
capable of looking to the child then I
think there's nothing wrong with that
but then shouldn't they just give the
child to the more financially stable
parent but financially being financially
stable doesn't make you a good parent
either it makes it much better for the
child I can give you money to like I can
give you so okay wouldn't you agree that
typically people that are financially
responsible typically are responsible in
other areas of their life in general
like I know there's exceptions but we're
talking about the rule when I look at
parents with Rich parents and their kids
have gone to private school those are
the most problematic kids well we're not
talking about wealth and no I'm just
reflecting it back to wealth so for me
for some reason money doesn't
necessarily make me feel like you're a
good parent you may be controlled in
your life like you may save well what
would you say indicates in a legal
perspective who's a good parent
you know I think feelings is so hard
things that you can't measure there's no
metrics no but legally it's finances
yeah if you can make sure because I just
don't know what else because if you're
if you can't support yourself in a kid
on some on some level that says you were
irresponsible and typically you are
irresponsible in not just one area of
your life but in multiple I think
legally I think they look at a child's
stability
um finances are like definitely a big
part of it and obviously the support the
families the support system the unit and
I feel like that's very important so if
for example I'm like [ __ ] with finances
and I don't have family it's just me and
my child they could probably give the
child to the dad who has his brothers
sisters aunties uncles cousins and he's
making more a bit more money but in
terms of finances just because I'm
struggling with my child doesn't mean
two like two income is always going to
be better than one so if he's given 200
pounds a month let's say that doesn't
affect him in that way to make it seem
like he's more financially stable he
could still be given 200 pounds and
earning less than me to to look after a
child takes however much I think if he
was living under the same roof the the
financial aspect will still be the same
exactly we'll still be spending money on
their child like child whether they're
living with a child or whether they
don't live exactly
um well yeah I mean I just think that I
don't like the idea of the government
like forcing them to spend money but
that's only if it's not 50 50 though
even so I just don't think you're
entitled to a man's money but men put
women on child support as well I that's
the exception it's not the rule
typically it's the other way around and
I'm not I'm not for that either I'm not
for child support at all so what do you
tell you what it is what do you think
what do you think should happen I think
like honestly you should make better
decisions of who you make a kid with
because like to me like there's always a
bailout for women if we make a bad
decision like someone always bails us
out and do you mean government
government everything so like for
example if we if someone gets fat
there's fat phobic right if someone if
someone if someone has a high body count
sleeps around their [ __ ] shaming like
they don't have the equivalent of that
for men and this is instance I'm saying
like you get money from the government
or or from or from the guy so I wouldn't
be able to comment on this because I
don't personally take child support
decision with my baby father but that's
the choice I made and I'm dealing with
it no and that's that's the thing I
respect people that take accountability
but it's like it's like to me I don't
think anyone should bail anyone out for
their bad decisions so if you choose to
make a child with a less a subpar guy I
don't think you're entitled to his money
you should have picked better but then
the mans have played just as much of a
part to create that child as the woman
no no because women are in charge of
birth it's your own fault if you get
pregnant because because we have we have
we have 10 to 15 forms of birth control
even if we get pregnant you can get an
abortion yeah but a man still has to
it's hot in here
um yeah but yeah but the thing is a man
having access to a woman's body